una imagen de Esperanza viene a mi mente
esta nave
es él y su comandante fuerte bueno
tiene la bandera de la Naciones Unidas
que vuela orgullosamente por un lado de
lo que uno ve es un vehículo una nave
como cualquiera que está en las naves
pero si mira más de cerca
esta nave es un símbolo de lo que
podemos lograr cuando actuamos juntos
está llena de grano ucraniano destinado
a la gente del cuerno de África millones
de los cuales están al borde del hambre
navegó a través de una vía de una zona
de guerra guiado por las partes del
conflicto como parte de una iniciativa
sin precedentes para llevar más
alimentos y fertilizadores desde Ucrania
y de Rusia
a quienes lo necesitan desesperadamente
aquellos
en dificultades
asegurar las futuras cosechas asegurar
bajos precios para consumidores en todas
partes o cránea y la federación rusa con
el respaldo de Turquía se reunieron para
hacer que su sucediera a pesar de las
grandes complejidades de los
negacionistas incluso de la guerra
algunos podrían decirle un milagro en el
mar
La tregua significa una acción
multilateral esta iniciativa de grano
del mar Negro es un pase seguro para las
naves que tienen y llevan suministros
alimenticios necesarios pero esta nave
también está llevando una de las
commodities más raras de esta época y es
la esperanza excelencias necesitamos
esperanza
y mucho más que eso necesitamos acción
para aliviar la crisis alimentaria
tenemos que enfrentarnos a la caída del
mercado de fertilizantes este año el
mundo tiene suficiente comida el
problema es la distribución pero si el
mercado de fertilizantes no está estable
El problema del siguiente año podría ser
el suministro de alimentos pero han
leído reportes de los granjeros en los
occidental que cada vez cultivan menos
cosechas menos por el precio o la falta
de disponibilidad de fertilizantes es
esencial seguir removiendo todos los
obstáculos que permanecen ante la
exportación de fertilizantes rusos y
otros productos como el amoniaco estos
productos no están sujetos a sanciones
y mantendremos los esfuerzos para
eliminar efectos indirectos
otra gran preocupación es el impacto de
Los Altos precios de gas en la
producción de fertilizantes de nitrógeno
eso también debe ser enfrentado con
seriedad
sin acción ahora
la carencia global de fertilizantes
pasará a ser una
carencia de alimentos mundial
necesitamos acciones en todas partes
señores lo estamos en ninguna momento de
ilusión esto es una gran dificultad el
descontento mundial está en el Horizonte
Los costos están aumentando la confianza
se está acabando la inequidad está
aumentando y nuestro planeta está
Ardiendo
la gente esta herida está sufriendo los
más vulnerables están sufriendo cada vez
más la carta de la Naciones Unidas y los
ideales que representa están en peligro
tenemos un deber de actuar y aún así
estamos enzarzados en una disfunción
global con la comunidad internacional no
está lista no está dispuesta a enfrentar
Esos grandes y dramáticos desafíos de
esta época esta crisis amenaza el futuro
de la humanidad y el destino de todo el
planeta
crisis como la guerra en Ucrania la
multiplicación de los conflictos
alrededor del mundo
crímenes como la emergencia
climática y la pérdida diversidad crisis
como los problemas financieros en países
en desarrollo
futuro de las metas de desarrollo global
en el momento en el que me volví el
secretario general desde entonces se ha
desarrollado una herramienta para
agregar genes neurotecnología que
conecta la tecnología con el sistema
nervioso humano ha progresado desde una
idea a una prueba conceptual la
criptomoneda y otras tecnologías de
blockchain están en todas partes
pero a lo largo de todas estas
tecnologías hay un bosque de banderas
rojas en las plataformas de redes
sociales
monetizan la negatividad del enojo están
causando grandes daños a las comunidades
y a la sociedad
discurso de odio es información
los blancos son las mujeres los grupos
nuestros datos están siendo comprados y
vendidos para influenciar nuestro
comportamiento mientras el spyware y el
espionaje están fuera de control sin
ningún tipo de preocupación por la
privacidad la Inteligencia artificial
puede comprometer la integridad de los
sistemas de información los medios
y la democracia en sí misma
la computación cuántica podría destruir
la ciberseguridad incrementar el riesgo
de mal funcionamiento para los sistemas
complejos
no tenemos la arquitectura para lidiar
con nada de esto excelencias El Progreso
en estos temas y más
son Rehenes de la atención geopolítica
nuestro mundo está en peligro y está
paralizado la división geopolítica que
están mirando el trabajo del seguro el
Consejo de Seguridad examinando la ley
internacional está minando
las tareas de las instituciones
democráticas mirando todo tipo de forma
cooperación internacional y no podemos
seguir de esa manera
incluso los grupos que están
establecidos afuera del sistema
multilateral por algunos miembros de la
comunidad internacional han caído en
esta trampa de la división geopolítica
como en el g20
en un escenario la relación es
internacionales debe pareciera moverse
hacia un mundo de G2 ahora
nos arriesgamos a pasar a un genada en
ninguna cooperación ningún diálogo
ningún ninguna solución colectiva de
problemas pero la realidad que estamos
viviendo ahora donde la lógica la lógica
de la cooperación y el diálogo es la
única posible en ningún grupo Solitario
puede tomar las
decisiones necesitamos una coalición de
todos excelencias
hoy
quisiera Resaltar tres áreas donde la
coalición del mundo debe urgentemente
superar las divisiones y actuar unidas
empieza con una misión
núcleo de las Naciones Unidas lograr y
sostener La Paz
mucha de la atención del mundo sigue
enfocada en la invasión Rusia de Ucrania
la guerra ha desatado una gran
destrucción una cantidad de violación de
derechos humanos de la ley internacional
humanitaria los últimos reportes sobre
sitios de sobre sitios de tumbas masivas
en edición es perturbadora este esos
combates han tomado miles de vida
millones han sido desplazados miles de
millones alrededor del mundo ya están
siendo afectados estamos viendo La
amenaza de estas peligrosas divisiones
entre el oeste y el resto del mundo en
los riesgos a la paz global y a la
seguridad son inmensos tenemos que
seguir trabajando por la paz alineados
con la carta de las Naciones Unidas y la
ley internacional a la vez los
conflictos y la crisis humanitaria están
pasando de un lado para otro incluso
ocurriendo fuera de los que muestran los
medios
se piden 32 mil millones de dólares se
consideran 32 mil millones de dólares
como la brecha
en Afganistán en las economías la
economía está en ruinas al menos la
mitad de los afganos enfrentan graves
niveles de hambre y los Derechos Humanos
particularmente los derechos de mujeres
y niñas están siendo
destruidos
en la República democrática del Congo
grupos armados en el ese San
aterrorizando civiles
y están incrementando las sesiones
regionales en el cuerno de África
La amenaza de la sequía están amenazando
las vías de 22 millones de personas en
Etiopía el conflicto se ha reanudado y
se necesita que las partes se
sensibilidades y vuelven a la mesa de
negociaciones
están destruyendo
las bases de la sociedad en Libia las
divisiones siguen poniendo en peligro al
país en las divisiones
o bueno las sanciones en curso amenaza
la estabilidad en Israel y Palestina
continúa la ocupación
mientras los prospectos de paz basados
en la solución de martes
parecen distantes en mi amar la
situación
de seguridad y Derechos Humanos está
deteriorizandose cada día en esta
situación
los niveles alarmantes de actividad
terrorista
y la necesidad ayuda humanitaria sigue
incrementando en Siria la violencia y
las dificultades prevalecen la lista va
iba Mientras tanto La amenaza nuclear La
amenaza la seguridad de plantas
nucleares están
agregándose hasta inestabilidad global
la conferencia de revisión del tratado
de una proliferación nuclear fracasó a
la hora de llegar a un consenso y el
trato nuclear con Irán sigue sigue
siendo distante
Pero hay algunos brillos de esperanza
en yemen
La tregua nacional es frágil para
Estados Unidos en Colombia el proceso de
paz está asentándose
necesitamos más acción concertada en
todas partes y mayor respeto por la ley
internacional y la protección de
Derechos Humanos en este mundo
debemos crear mecanismos de diálogo
y mediación para sanar las divisiones
por eso es que tras el elementos de una
nueva agenda para la paz
en mi reporte sobre nuestra agenda común
estamos comprometidos a sacar el mayor
provecho de cada herramienta diplomática
para
la resolución pacífica de conflictos
como se dice la carta de los Derechos
Humanos negociación investigación
mediación conciliación
arbitraje y acuerdos jurídicos
excelencias
el liderazgo femenino la participación
debe estar al frente de todo y también
debemos priorizar la prevención y la
construcción de paz Eso significa
fortalecer fuerza
la evaluación estratégica
tratar de taclear la violencia y
enfrentar amenazas emergentes como la
ciber Guerra y las armas autónomas
letales también significa expandir el
rol de grupos regionales fortalecen del
cuidado de la paz y considerar el
desarme y la no proliferación prevenir y
contrarrestar el terrorismo y
asegurarnos de que haya
responsabilidades Y eso significa
reconocer derechos humanos como la como
lo fundacional para la prevención mi
pedido a la acción sobre Derechos
Humanos resalta la centralidad de los
Derechos Humanos los refugiados y la ley
humanitaria
todo lo que hacemos debemos reconocer
que los Derechos Humanos son el camino a
resolver tensiones acabar los conflictos
y forjar una basurera excelencias hay
otra batalla que Debemos enfrentar
nuestra guerra suicida en contra de la
naturaleza la crisis climática es el
tema definitivo de nuestra era y debe
ser la primera prioridad de cada
gobierno y cada organización
multilateral y aún así
la acción climática está
lejos de las prioridades a pesar del
respaldo público alrededor del mundo
la emisión de gases invernaderos
globales debe ser recortada en 45% de
aquí a 2030 para tener a cualquier
esperanza de llegar a una
economía cero emisiones de aquí 2050 y
aún así las emisiones están aumentando a
niveles
récord
está dejado un incremento de 14%.
podemos tener un encuentro con el
desastre climático recientemente lo
ubico mis profesores Pakistán donde un
tercio del país está sumergido en un
Monzón bastante agresivo le pasamos
viendo en todas partes
el último año nos llevó a las peores
ondas de calor de las últimas décadas la
sequía en China en Estados Unidos en
otros países las familias en el cuerno
África un millón de especies al riesgo
de extinción ninguna región está sin ser
afectada y no hemos visto nada aún los
veranos más fuertes de hoy podrían ser
los veranos más suaves del mañana una
vez
con cada desastre temático sabemos que
mujeres y niñas son las más afectadas la
crisis climática es un estudio
de la injusticia
moral y económica
los países más pobres y más vulnerables
aquellos que contribuyen menos a esta
crisis están cargando su peor impacto
Mientras tanto la industria de
combustibles fósiles está
esta mientras sus presupuestos de los
hogares más pobres sufren
excelencia digamoslo como es nuestro
mundo es adicto a los combustibles
fósiles y es momento de una intervención
necesitamos hacer que estas compañías
sean responsables y Eso incluye los
bancos
instituciones financieras fondos que
siguen invirtiendo
y acabar aumentar la polución de
carbonos esta máquina de relaciones
públicas que está recibiendo millones
para proteger a las Industrias a las
Industrias de combustibles fósiles
before así como pasó con las Industrias
de tabaco los lobistas de los doctores
han tratado de sacar información
negativa
de estas industrias fósiles deberían
disminuir su intervención de relaciones
públicas y trabajar por otras cosas esto
no se puede acabar de un día a otro
la transición de combustibles no va a
dejar ningún país al lado pero es
importante que se les ponga bajo avisos
a estas industrias los la gente que las
evolución debe pagar
hay que fiscalizarlas incluso desde los
países más pobres estos fondos deben ser
redirigidos de dos maneras a países que
están sufriendo Perdidos por esa crisis
climática y a las personas que luchan
con los precios de la energía y con
obtener alimentos
apenas estoy apelando todos los líderes
que entiendan y que lleven a cabo las
metas del acuerdo de París escuchen a
las peticiones de su pueblo por el
cambio inviertan en soluciones que
lleven a la crecimiento económico
sostenible y Déjenme Resaltar 3 la
energía renovable en general tres veces
más trabajos ya es más barato que los
combustibles fósiles y es la mejor
manera
de asegurar la estabilidad de los
precios energéticos los países el
desarrollo Necesitan ayuda para hacer
estos cambios Incluyendo a través de
coaliciones Internacionales para
respaldar la transición energética en
economía emergentes clave segundo ayudar
a países a adaptarse a los choques
climáticos la construcción de
resiliencia de países del desarrollo es
una inversión inteligente en una
los países desarrollados acordaron para
eso es un acuerdo que debe ser logrado
la adaptación debe ser la mitad de todas
nuestras finanzas climáticas los bancos
de desarrollo multilaterales deben
aumentar su acción
las grandes economías son responsables y
deberá ser que eso suceda también En
tercer lugar
enfrentarse a la pérdida de los
desastres
es momento de superar estas discusiones
sin fin los países vulnerables necesitan
acciones significativas
la pérdida y el daño está
hirviendo a la gente viviendo la
economía deben ser enfrentados ahora
empezando en el 27
Esta es una inquietud fundamental de la
justicia climática de la solidaridad
internacional y la confianza y a la vez
tenemos que asegurarnos de que cada
persona comunidad y nación
tenga acceso a sistemas de advertencia
temprana en los próximos cinco años
y debemos dirigirnos a esta crisis de
biodiversidad Al
hacer que la conferencia en diciembre
funcione el mundo debe acordar
en un marco de acción de biodiversidad
con metas ambiciosas para detener y
reversar la pérdida de biodiversidad
proveer financiamiento apropiado y
eliminar subsidios que destruyen
ecosistemas de los cuales defendemos
también les pido que intensifiquen los
esfuerzos para finalizar
esos acuerdos vinculantes para conservar
el uso sostenible de la biodiversidad
marítima debemos proteger al océano
ahora y de aquí en adelante
excelencias la crisis climática está
presente en cada clima
una situación de costo climático está
siendo está afectarnos a todo sumado
esta Guerra de Ucrania
al menos 1.6 mil millones de personas se
están enfrentando graves dificultades
situaciones económicas por la pandemia
incremento de los precios alimentarios
cada vez una mayor inflación una falta
de acceso a la finanzas a lo financiero
esta crisis se está alimentando una a
otra combinando inequidades cree
bastante dificultades devastadoras
retrasando la transición energética y
amenazando con una desmonte financiera
mundial
el estallido social puede ser Inevitable
y no tiene que ser de esta manera
un mundo sin pobreza extrema sin hambre
sin guerra no es imposible está al
alcance eso es lo que se visualiza en la
agenda de 2030 con las metas de
sostenibilidad pero no es el mundo que
parece que hayamos elegido
debido a nuestras decisiones colectivas
el desarrollo sostenible en todas partes
está en riesgo
las metas de sostenibilidad son una
llamada de ayuda incluso las metas
incluso las medidas en Alimentación en
educación cada vez hay más gente tiene
más hambre cada vez la gente tiene menos
educación la inequidad de género está
aumentando en las vías de las mujeres
están haciéndose peores desde la pobreza
las elecciones alrededor de la salud
reproductiva hasta la seguridad personal
la excelencias los países en desarrollo
están recibiendo golpes de todas partes
y necesitamos acción concertada hoy
estoy pidiendo el lanzamiento de un
estímulo de metas de sostenibilidad
para
aumentar las posibilidades de desarrollo
de países en desarrollo en la próxima
Cumbre el g20 en Bali es el punto de
inicio
este estímulo tiene cuatro componentes
en primer lugar de banco de desarrollo
multilateral el Banco Mundial y
contrapartes regiones deben incrementar
los fondos a los países en desarrollo
vinculados con inversiones En las metas
de desarrollo sostenible
los bancos como tal necesitan más ayuda
financiera y luego necesitan levantar
sus condiciones de préstamo y aumentar
su apetito por el riesgo para que los
fondos lleguen a los que lo necesitan
los países es desarrollo particularmente
las pequeñas Islas enfrentan demasiado
los obstáculos al Acceder al
financiamiento que necesita para
invertir en su gente y en su futuro en
segundo lugar el alivio a la deuda
esa iniciativa debe ser extendida y
mejorada pero también necesitamos un
mecanismo efectivo un alivio de duda
para países en deuda para países
desarrollados países con ingresos medios
quienes emiten créditos deben considerar
mecanismos de deducción de deuda
y esto puede salvar vidas pudo haberlo
hecho en Pakistán que Está inundado no
solamente con agua sino con deudas
criterios de préstamo en superar el
producto incluido estas dimensiones que
afectan a los países en desarrollo mi
tercer lugar una expansión de la
liquidez Le pido al fondo monetario
internacional a los grandes bancos
centrales que me expandan sus
instalaciones de
liquidez significativamente
derechos especiales
permiten que los países el desarrollo
inviertan en recuperación y en derechos
de sostenibilidad hay metas de
sostenibilidad pero deben ser
distribuidas de acuerdo con cosas
existentes
beneficiando los que lo necesitan
necesitamos hemos estado esperando por
19 meses y las cantidades que estamos
escuchando son mínimas
eso debe ser manejado de manera distinta
basada en la solidaridad con los países
en desarrollo en cuarto lugar le pido a
los gobiernos que empoderen fondos
especiales como Gabriel fondo global y
el fondo global climático las economías
del g20 deberían expandir estos fondos
para patrocinar a los metas de
desarrollo
excelencias
esto que estoy proponiendo los estímulos
son esenciales pero es solamente medias
intermedias el sistema de hoy fue creado
por países ricos para servir a sus
intereses hace muchas décadas y se
expande y termina en inequidad requiere
una reforma estructural profunda en mi
reporte sobre las propuestas de agenda
común se propone un nuevo trato para
rebalancear los poderes y los recursos
entre países el desarrollo países
africanos particularmente
deben ser mejor representados e
instituciones financieras Espero que
estos miembros encuentren la oportunidad
para transformar esas ideas en
soluciones concretas incluido en la
Cumbre del futuro en 2024 excelencias
las diferencias entre países en
desarrollo entre norte y del sur de Los
privilegiados y el resto se vuelven cada
vez más peligrosas
es la raíz de las tensiones geopolíticas
eso envenena cada áreas de cooperación
desde las vacunas desde las sanciones
desde el comercio pero actuando como uno
podemos tener algún camino de Esperanza
pedir el cambio exigir mucho más de los
líderes
patrocinando a gente joven que están
buscando un futuro más Pacífico y mejor
patrocinar a mujeres y niñas que viven y
luchan por aquellos a los que se les
niegan sus derechos humanos
hay una esperanza para que la sociedad
encuentre y construya comunidades más
justas patrocinio mejor para la ciencia
y la academia para detener las
enfermedades
una esperanza
en las ayudas humanitarias
está con todos del lado de todos
entendemos que los ideales deben ser
hechos realidad en las vidas de las
personas desarrollemos soluciones
comunes a problemas comunes
basados en la buena voluntad de la
confianza y los derechos compartidos por
cada derecho por cada ser humano
trabajemos como una colección del mundo
como naciones humanas como Naciones
Unidas Muchas gracias